I teach seventh grade they are still
performing on the fourth grade
level I don't care how you flip it turn
it swing swing it SW it they still
performing on a fourth grade level a't
nobody talking about how they just keep
moving passing them on they just keep
passing them on passing them on passing
them on passing them on passing them on
passing them on I can put as many zeros
in this grab as I want to they going to
move that child to the eighth grade next
year it is like it's it's a it's just
it's a major problem I I don't know how
else to to put it we've got gener
generation of kids who are not being
educated would you say it's time for
everyone to panic they're going to
graduate like barely knowing how to read